네. 안녕하세요. 여기 어디서 오늘은
노년동에 와 있습니다. 언주역과
신노년역 사이에 있는 건물인데
봉원사로 대루병 코너 있어요. 그래서
입지적으로도 굉장히 좀 좋습니다.
사옥으로 쓰기에도 너무 좋은 건물인데
회사 대표님을 좀 모셔 가지고
간단하게 인터뷰 소개랑 공간 소개를
여러분들한테 해 드리도록 하겠습니다.
가시죠.
네. 그래서 여기 회사 사혹을 쓰고
계신 어제로의 임지한 대표님
모셨습니다. 어 간단하게 회사 소개
좀 부탁드릴게요. 부동산 프로세스의
모든 과정을 리나우스를 하고 있는
이제 디벨로퍼 회사입니다.
>> 어 일단은이 건물은 몇 년도에 매입을
하셨던 거죠?네
>> 저희가 2021년에 매입을 이제
했고요. 방금은 2022년에 저희가
치렀습니다. 얼마예? 저희가 이제
3종이랑 일반 주거가 섞여 있는 조선
상업지라고 통상 얘기하는 그런데 지로
치면은 이제 2억 4천에 매입을
했습니다.
>> 그럼 땅이 한 몇 평 정도 되나요?
>> 땅이 240평.
>> 면적은 지금 옆면적이 여기가
1450평입니다.
층는 이제 지하 4층에 지상 8층.
>> 그래서 지하를 굉장히 많이 파져 있는
데여서 그래서 좀 주차가 좀 잘 돼
있다는 장점이 있는 그런 건물입니다.
>> 리모델링 기간은 얼마나 걸리셨습니까?
세 달 정도 걸렸고요.
>> 많이 안 걸렸어요.
>> 네네. 저희가 리모델링을 이제 많이
건드리진 않았어요. 리모델링은 결국
핵심이 얼마나 빠르고 얼마나 싸게
하느냐가 좀 관건이다 보니까 저희가
대신 계획을 면밀하게 해서 설계
기간은 한 3개월 거의 시공 기간이랑
비슷할 정도로네
>> 설계 기간을 좀 가져서 진행을
했습니다.이
>> 짧은 기간에 하기 되게 너무 멋지게
한 거 같은데 효율성 있게 되게 한
거 같아요. 그래서 여기도 살릴 수
있는 거 최대한 살리고 되게 리모델링
잘한 사례라고 좀 보여지는데 옥상부터
좀 올라가 가지고 건물 한번 좀 보여
주세요.
>> 네. 알겠습니다. 알겠습니다.이
>> 건물의 이제 특성이 저희가 이제 살
때부터이 뷰를 보고 이제 매입을 하게
됐는데요. 왜냐면이 로케이션상 좀
높은 위치에 있고 저희가 지대가
낮은데 이제 이종 일반 주어질이기
때문에 높게 올라갈 수가 없어요.
여기가 강남임에도 불구하고 저기
남산하고 이제 북한산까지 보이는 뷰를
가지고 있는 곳입니다. 박층에서도
적풍강을 좀 끌어들여서 안에 사람들이
즐길 수 있는 그런 거를 좀 신경을
써서 이제 설계를 했었고요.
VIP들을 모시고 한다든지 아니면
저희 지인들을 모시고 파티를 하기도
하고 또 대접을 하기도 하고
>> 또 내부 구성원끼리 이제 즐기기도
하고 요런 공간으로 잘 쓰고
있습니다.
>> 그리고 이건 천창이네요.
>> 네, 맞습니다. 계획할 때부터
8층이랑 7층에 이따가 내부 계단이
있는데 그 내부 계단의 위치에 딱
맞춰서 천창을 뚫어서 좀 자연체강이
들어오고 그래서 좀 항상 밝은
분위기를 낼 수 있도록 이렇게 연출을
했습니다. 하나하나 신경을 또 많이
쓰시 또 내려가서 한번 또 보여
>> 주시겠습니다네.
어 여기는 이제 저희 건물
모형이고요.
>> 저희가요 건물이 강난고 아름다운
거물상을 3년 전에 받아서
>> 그때 이제 모형도 만들고 이제 전시도
했었던 그런 경험이 있습니다.
>> 네. 여기 송자갈로 깔아서 조금 밝은
분위기로 8층은 일부러 좀 연출을
했고요. 여기 보시다시피 아까 위에
있었던 천창에서 자연 체강이 내려오고
78층을 이어 가지고 이제 내부
계단으로 만들어서 같이 업무 공간으로
쓰고 있어요. 그리고 7층이랑 6층도
아예 다른 분위기로 일부러 지금
연출을 해서 사용을 하고 있습니다.
그리고 여기 7층은 이제 라운지경
강연장처럼도 쓰고 특히 건설 쪽에서는
주기적으로 한 달에 한 번씩 모여서
각 현장별로 있었던 일들을 여기서
모아서 지식을 서로 교류하는 그런
장소로도 쓰고 또 앞에는 이제
테라스가 있어서 그 휴계로 쓸 수
있게 이렇게 구성을 했습니다.
>> 와이 공간도 진짜 너무 좋네요.
>> 저희가 6층은 설대본부가 쓰고
있고요. 그래서 별도의 이제 프로젝트
전시 공간이 있고 제일 중요하게
여겼던게이 풍광을 이제이 내부에서도
즐길 수 있게 하는 거를 좀 중요시
여겼었어요. 그래서 여기 라운지로
만들어서 좀 방문객이라든지 구성원들도
이제 일을 하다가 나와서 리프레시할
수 있게 만들었습니다.
>> 로비가 정말 좀 화려한 거 같아요.
이렇게 다 거울로 했는데 이렇게 한
이유가 있으세요? 저희가 이제
리모델링 할 때 고민이 어쨌든
오피스들이 있으니까 입구를 저희는
굉장히 중요시 여겼거든요. 사실 엄청
큰 프라임 오피스는 아니어서 로비를
제대로 갖추기는 좀 부담이 됐었고
면적이 너무 넓진 않지만 개방감은
느꼈으면 좋겠다라는 생각에 천상까지
다 이제 미러를 쓰는 거를 저희가
적용을 했습니다. 그래서 들어오면은
대부분 좀 어 되게 넓어 보인다는
인식이 좀 있는 공간입니다.
>> 너무 잘 만드신 거 같습니다.
>> 네.
지하 1층에 왔는데 일단 주차장이
너무 좋은 거 같아요.
>> 아, 네. 또 건물을 매입할 때
중요하게 여겼던게 차량에서의 진입감을
좀 많이 고민을 했었고 자주식으로
들어올 수 있다는 장점이 있었고이
자주 주차를 하고 여기가 지하
4층까지 주차장이 있습니다. 그래서
카리프트가 두 대가 있기 때문에
딜레이 없이 주차를 좀 많이 할 수
있는 장점이 있었고요. 그리고 여기
리모델링을 할 때 저희가 일부러
바닥은 건드리지 않았어요. 리모델링
할 때 이제 중요한게 비용을 얼마나
아끼면서 효과를 낼 수 있느냐하는데
바닥은 건드리면 방수에서부터 여러
가지를 사실은 다시 해야 되거든요.
서 저희가 주목했던 건 이제
천장입니다.
>> 그래서 천장은 걷어내고 디자인적인
요소를 감의한 다음에이 조명을 조금
신경을 써서 약간 그 전보다는 훨씬
세련된 느낌으로 완전히 분위기를
바꾸는데 신경을 많이 썼습니다.
>> 너무 좋은 거 같아. 그러니까 이게
사실 약간 호텔 느낌 나거든요. 호텔
주차장 느낌이 나는데 되게 효율적으로
리모델링 자랑 거 같습니다.
>> 네.
아까 말씀드렸던 저희가 직접 운영하고
있는 1층의 레스토랑입니다. 저희가
직접 콘텐츠를 좀 운영해 보자라는
생각에 만들게 되었습니다. 어 너무
고급스러운데 한번 들어가 들어가서
볼까요? 이것도 다 직접 인테리어
하시
>> 네. 저희가 직접 로고도 만들고
브랜딩도 하고 인테리어도 다 저희가
직접 했습니다. 그리고 좀 오픈
키친으로 만들어서 이제 셰프들이 직접
요리하고 있는 모습을 보면서 음식을
먹을 수 있
>> 너무 좋다. 그런 식으로 구성을
했어요.
>> 아니 클라이언트분들이 저기서 상담하고
여기서 식사하면 계약하실 거.
>> 네. 어서 저걸 좀 다 돌아봤는데
마지막으로 혹시 예비 건축주분들한테
혹시 해 주고 싶으신 말이 좀
있으실까요? 우선 전 사의 장점에
대해서 좀 말씀을 드리고 싶은데 그
회사를 운영할 때 확실히 사혹이
있으면은 구성원들의 안정감이라든지
자부심 같은게 늘어나서 부동산 자산
가치도 물론 있지만 사업 운영의
포텐셜이 올라가는 그런 효과도 굉장히
큰 무형의 가치라고 생각을 합니다.
그래서 4억에 대해서 좀 고민하시는
분들이라면은 이런 부분을 꼭
고려하시면 더 좋은 의사 결정을 할
수 있을 것 같고요. 리모델링을
생각하시는 분들이라면은 제가 꼭
강조하고 싶은 건 할 때 잘해야
됩니다. 비용이랑 시간의 제약 때문에
주저하기가 싫거든요. 저도 돌이켜
보면은 그때 과감한 선택을 했으면 더
좋았겠다 하는 부분들이 있어요.
그래서 약간은 더 과감하게 해도
결국은 다 돌아올 수 있다. 요런
생각을 하시고 의사 결정하면 좋을 것
같습니다.
>> 아, 그래서 오늘 나와 주셔서 너무
감사드리고 그 유튜브도 만드셨죠?
>> 아, 네. 같습니다. 이제 랜드로드
가이드라는 채널이 있습니다. 저희가
한 프로젝트들 더 깊은 얘기가
궁금하신 분들 있으면 꼭 한번 찾아
주세요. 구독과 좋아요 많이 눌러
주시고 오늘 영상 여기까지
하겠습니다. 감사합니다.